chloroquine colchicine courir c'est in
fine et non de médicaments sur lesquels
on fonde beaucoup d'espoir parce qu'il
pourrait stopper les effets du virus
avant que la vie des patients sont en
danger
pour y voir plus clair
j'ai parlé à deux spécialistes qui
participent à l'effort collectif contre
le nouveau virus
avec son équipe nathalie grandvaux temps
notamment de développer un antiviral
universelle qui pourrait nous sortir du
pétrin face à n'importe quel virus
mon deuxième expert c'est le dr jean
claude tardif c'est lui qui a lancé un
vaste essai clinique le 23 mars dernier
pour tester l'efficacité de la
colchicine c'est un médicament qui est
employée depuis des centaines d'années
pour traiter la goutte mais deux
scientifiques cherchent pas à s'attaquer
directement aux frasques de leur cible
ce sont les cellules une histoire si le
virus arrive dans nos voies
respiratoires est bien ici en tri dans
nos cellules
mais le système immunitaire fait son
travail de l'enfer dallaire il envoie
des messagers pour appeler des globules
blancs en renfort 7 les messageries qui
sont envoyées on appelle des cytokines
qui vont alerter le système immunitaire
blanchette être produites en trop grande
quantité on appelle ça une tente et de
cytokines août et c'est tout et cela
conduit à des dommages au niveau des
tissus d'autres systèmes respiratoire
vous vous souvenez sûrement que les
enfants quand ils attrapent le nouveau
corner virus il souffre beaucoup moins
de complications que les adultes c'est
exactement ce qui a mis jean claude
tardif sur la piste de la colchicine on
pense que la réponse immunitaire des
enfants pour être freiné beaucoup plus
rapidement que celle des adultes
et ça ça pourrait expliquer pourquoi il
s'en tire mieux
l'inflammation ça regroupe une foule de
processus biochimiques différents
/ dr tardif mis sur l'accueil schisme ce
parce qu'on pense qu'elle peut agir
précisément sur cette campagne stocking
et donc c'est inutile de se ruer vers
n'importe quel anti-inflammatoires qu'on
retrouve dans les pharmacies et tout
comme si jamais une bonne idée
d'utiliser un médicament pour soigner
autre chose que ce pour quoi il a été
conçu la stratégie n'a pas les grands
vos est complètement différente
ici on parle de développer un antiviral
c'est à dire de cibler les mécanismes de
nos cellules que le virus utilise pour
se multiplient un virus c'est un
président c'est à dire qu'il est pas
autonomie doit pas se multiplier si les
fins dans un organisme qu on appelle l
autre donc ils utilisent les mécanismes
biologiques de l être humain
dans le cas du centre où les deux poules
se multiplier l'un deux choix soit on va
utiliser des molécules qui vont cibler
des composantes du virus et qui vont
faire en sorte que quand ils sont liés à
ces composantes là on a plus de
réplication du virus c'est la stratégie
traditionnelle stratégie que nous on a
choisi
on essaye de comprendre ce qui se passe
dans la cellule qu'est ce qui est
nécessaire pour que le virus
le ou les virus se répand et on espère
trouver en fait des drames qui vont
pouvoir cibler ces mécanismes là et qui
pourront être utilisées pour bloquer
aucun chiffre qui risque de se répliquer
il ya plusieurs molécules qui sont
actuellement à l'essai qui après
exactement le même mécanisme comme la
chloroquine vous en avez peut-être déjà
entendu parler parce que la chloroquine
on dirait que la planète entière s'est
enflammée d'entousiasme pour les
premières qui représente par rapport à
la coved 19 pour un coût et de crêpes et
de game se rappeler que c'est toujours
plus sage de garder la tête froide quand
nous présente des résultats miraculeux
il ya d'ailleurs beaucoup de
scientifiques qui ont émis des réserves
par rapport aux études qui sont parus
sur la chloroquine ce qu'on peut retenir
de toutes les démarches en cours c'est
que les tactiques des scientifiques sont
créatives multiples puis franchement
encourageante juste au canada le
gouvernement fédéral a accordé 50 3
millions de dollars en fonds d'urgence à
près de 100 scientifiques qui vont
s'appliquer à décrire ce nouveau virus à
développer des outils de diagnostic et
des traitements
je pense qu
recherches avancent plus vite n'a jamais
avancé jusqu'ici et que ça c'est très
important parc aplatir la courbe c'est
important mais calme et n'attend pas
être aussi